this gabriel sits down with the two
fouls hassan whiteside comes in
whiteside made some very big plays in
game one alley up to james
and there's anthony davis with a perfect
pass come out of the gate
side out of bounds this is a setup you
got to see it if you're the
blazers they don't they allow a direct
dive to the cup on point pass from
anthony davis lebron james
on a mission early in this ball game
backs in double team
re post double teamed again finds davis
for the slam
he's got to make the right adjustments
because you're not going to win this
battle
and you could have
another three
well when they're in the double big men
rotation
i mean you gotta close somebody's gotta
close
and you gotta pressure the ball that's
like allowing a great quarterback
to sit there with no pressure he's gonna
put it right on the money
right now for the lakers
davis suspends step back puts it in
anthony davis a brilliant performance
tonight
a shot fake drive spin step back
that's a good defense by whiteside and
just phenomenal offensive skill
well it's the most points per game of
lebron